y pasamos a nuestra sección de economía
con jorge hurtado jorge un saludo para
usted qué tal angela muy bien gracias
jorge vamos a comenzar en argentina el
fm y destacó el compromiso del nuevo
ministro de economía de no alterar las
metas pactadas con ese país es que el
organismo emitió un comunicado tras esta
reunión entre sergio massa que es el
nuevo ministro de economía de argentina
y kristalina georgieva la gerente del
fondo monetaria internacional todo
indica que se logra el acuerdo por la
segunda revisión del programa la titular
del fmi destacó que durante el encuentro
felicitó a massa por su nombramiento y
por los fuertes pasos de su equipo
económico para estabilizar los mercados
y según ella revertir el escenario de
alta volatilidad
georgieva también destacó que los
compromisos de masa para alcanzar un
déficit primario del 2.5 por ciento del
producto interno bruto en 2022 y del 19
para el año 2023 massa escribió en
twitter que sostuvo esta reunión muy
positiva con la secretaria también del
tesoro de eeuu janet yellen y otros
funcionarios estadounidenses pese al
éxito de los encuentros los economistas
aumentaron su estimación de la inflación
anual en argentina este año para el 95
mientras el país lucha por superar una
prolongada crisis económica marcada
sobre todo por la subida de los precios
y los cambios constantes en el gabinete
económico vamos ahora a panamá arrancó
la audiencia preliminar del caso de los
sobornos de odebrecht está considerada
angela la mayor trama de corrupción en
la historia de ese país la audiencia
inició este lunes con 83 imputados entre
ellos dos ex presidentes de la república
luego de haber sido suspendida la
audiencia el pasado mes de julio la
jueza a cargo escuchó los alegatos de
las partes para decidir en un plazo de
30 días hábiles sobre el llamamiento a
juicio la fiscalía pedirá enjuiciar a 49
personas 46 de que natural es una
persona jurídica que están imputados por
el delito de blanqueo de capitales y
otras dos personas naturales por
corrupción de servidores públicos y
blanqueo de capitales escuchemos lo que
dijo al llegar a esta audiencia frank de
lima ex ministro de economía y finanzas
de panamá
aquí estamos 48 que estamos listos para
enfrentar la justicia de verdad como
usted día se haga justicia no como nació
este caso desde el inicio la
investigación fue un caso el vino siendo
sesgado recordemos que cuando estalló la
valla pto
procurador de brasil dijo que la
procuradora en ese momento que ella por
ser está admitiendo manda información
y seguimos en la región en colombia
podría subir el costo de los
combustibles org- es una medida que está
causando mucho revuelo y que fue
anunciada en twitter por lex por el
presidente gustavo petro el argumento de
esta probable subida es reducir el
déficit en el fondo de estabilización de
precios de los combustibles este es un
fondo que se creó para atemperar los
precios de los combustibles por ejemplo
si el precio del petróleo sube a nivel
internacional se carga la diferencia a
este fondo
pero desde la guerra en ucrania los
precios se han mantenido altos causando
un déficit acumulado a las arcas
colombianas que ahora deben financiar de
forma que el precio del galón de la
gasolina pasaría de nueve mil doscientos
pesos colombianos hasta los 16 mil la
pregunta es qué tan gradual será este
aumento y cuando empezaría hay que
destacar que colombia es el tercer país
de américa latina con el precio de la
gasolina más barato petro afirma que el
déficit en este fondo de subsidios para
combustibles es de casi 40 millones de
pesos anuales lo que representa casi la
mitad del déficit presupuestario
varios expertos señalan que continuar
subsidiando los combustibles en este
país impide que estos recursos vayan a
programas sociales y vamos a terminar en
europa en parís a unos 500 repartidores
de uber it se protestaron en la sede de
la transnacional jorge porque bueno esto
fue en rechazo al despido o la
suspensión de dos mil quinientas cuentas
de su plataforma que supuestamente
utilizaban identidades falsas muchos
argumentan que llevan años trabajando
con uber alegando que la empresa era
consciente de que sus usuarios suelen
ser inmigrantes indocumentados que
utilizan documentos de identidad
prestados para tratar de abrir estas
cuentas la empresa anunció que 2.500 de
las aproximadamente 60.000 cuentas
fueron identificadas como fraudulentas y
dijo que los usuarios cuyas cuentas
fueron bloqueadas aún podían apelar a la
decisión de la plataforma vr y otros
operadores de servicio a domicilio
insisten en que los trabajadores son
autónomos pero los tribunales de toda
europa todavía no se ponen de acuerdo a
la figura legal que deben tener muy
complicada la cosa jorge y cuál es la
cifra del día
327 millones de dólares género el
festival rock in río en brasil hubo 150
conciertos en siete jornadas tuvo un
impacto de aproximadamente
1.700 millones de riise el festival
generó 28.000 empleos directos benefició
principalmente al sector turístico al
atraer a unos 360 mil visitantes durante
estas jornadas bueno pues el
agradecimiento es para ustedes jorge y
nos vamos ahora para el debate
[Música]